thank you
georges i'd like to thank the presidency
also for the excellent cooperation we've
been enjoying over the past few months
together
and good morning everybody
now for two years now
i've enjoyed the trust of president
juncker president trusk and the members
of the european council as well as the
european parliament in my position
i have attempted to operate methodically
and calmly
to ensure that the decisions of the
european union as expressed
by the european council in its decisions
and guidelines on the one hand
and also by the european
parliament in a number of its
resolutions i've attempted to
pursue these in an orderly fashion now
if we look at these guidelines and
decisions
they reflect first of all the desire to
be united
and that has been expressed since
june 2016 by the european institutions
and in my capacity i am i
am a worker hopefully a qualified worker
on behalf of the 27 in nurturing this
unity on a daily basis
and ensuring transparency interest
as part of the process of dialogue
so we're talking about unity we're
talking about defending the interests of
the european union
and indeed the foundations of the
european union which the uk
is very familiar with because we've been
constructing these for the past 44 years
we're talking about the single market in
all of its dimensions which is our main
achievement
in the current global context and for
the future
an orderly withdrawal of the united
kingdom
this is something which has on a daily
basis
been our objective and it remains
our objective obviously
an orderly withdrawal implies
the best possible conditions for the
second set of negotiations equally
important in my mind
the negotiations for the future
partnership with the united kingdom
which will would and will remain a
friend partner and ally
so this explains
how and why we have been working on this
for the past two years now
on the eve of the european council
we have examined the situation in london
and president trusk has given
theresa may the opportunity to to to
show the way forward
timeline a road map this is something
the european union needs
in order to enable it to take the right
decisions
now a new element in this very very
serious and complex
context we're operating within
is of course the fact that we have
had cross-party discussions
initiated finally with labor
by theresa may
we all expressed our hopes and
expectations
in this regard
in other words with regard to these
cross-party negotiations
our expectations and our hope
that this dialogue will conclude with a
positive result
which will allow us at last to have
a positive majority emerge
with regard to this withdrawal agreement
and this is something i was able to
reiterate this morning
to ministers if the uk wishes to leave
the eu in an orderly fashion the only
way to do so is the base
is based on the withdrawal agreement
which we agreed upon together
so as i said this cross-party dialogue
is the new element which
could lead to a request which we would
be then willing
not only to agree to but also to
implement for our future elite relations
you will have heard me say on a number
of occasions first of all
that the withdrawal agreement is not
going to be reopened
is not up for negotiation again that
continues to be the case secondly the
political
declaration which will set the framework
for future relations
can be improved we can
provide it with increased an increased
level of ambition
if that is the wish of the uk
clearly there is one point which i think
needs to be stated quite clearly and
that is
that these ambitions with regard to
future relations
which could for example consist of
adding and i say here
adding to
a free trade agreement on which we've
agreed with
the uk already that's a minimum level in
other words it would avoid
involve adding to this free trade
agreement
for example a customs union a genuine
customs union
and we are willing to
improve and amend the political
liberation rapidly within a few hours
or days
but the request we await and expect
from the uk as a result of this
cross-party dialogue is one which needs
to respect
the principles underlying the approach
of the european council
and the european parliament and respect
what we are and what we will continue to
be
and i think this is something worth
recalling
we're talking here about the integrity
of the internal market
the decision-making autonomy of the 27
and the indivisibility of the four
freedoms
we are not willing to compromise
in any way the very foundations of the
european union
which are based on this single market
and the the genuine ecosystem which
it entails which protects businesses and
in particular
protects consumers that's a point which
needs to be
understood very very clearly and if
that's the case then we
are willing straight away and this is
something president juncker has said on
a number of occasions he said this
recently at the plenary of the european
parliament we
are ready straight away to get down to
amending and improving and providing
more ambition to
the political declaration which would
set the framework for future relations
now why am i stressing this particular
point and
and these new elements in the process
which we hope will allow for a new
process to emerge in the house of
commons
and will allow ultimately for
a new majority to emerge with regard to
this agreement and this new political
declaration
why am i stressing this so much well
clearly it's because this is what would
provide meaning to the request which the
uk prime minister has submitted for an
extension
and this is all i wish to say on this
for today
forgive me for not dwelling on this
further but this is a matter
for the leaders of the european union
tomorrow
this extension has to serve a purpose
it's got to serve a purpose to provide
more time if necessary to ensure that
the political process
i've described can be crowned with
success
and that this majority can be attained
the issue of the length of the extension
which has been discussed at great length
with its possible pros and cons
i'm not going to make a statement on
that
from from my vantage point it's not up
to me to do so but
the duration of the extension has got to
be in line
in any case with the purpose being
striven for that's what i would say
right now
it's got to to to serve a purpose or a
name
no a final word one of the ministers
said something this morning
the aim of all this is to
achieve an orderly withdrawal
and i i would prefer to say this rather
than to
imply that our objective is to avoid a
no deal because i know there will never
be
a decision taken by the european union
and no deal
would never be a decision taken by the
european union we have been working
towards
an agreement a treaty if you like
not just a deal we're talking about 600
pages or so
setting out very specifically guarantees
for citizens for ireland
for the beneficiaries of european funds
and a lot of other domains
which could be jeopardized so it's more
than a deal it's a it's a genuine treaty
we have worked towards this treaty
together with the british
and that means that no deal would never
be a decision
of the european union it would
always be the responsibility of the
united kingdom to tell us what they want
if they want to stop the brexit process
they can do so they can revoke
article 50 if they want to
allow for a deal to take place or indeed
to prevent a no deal
as we've heard from the house of commons
if they want to avoid a no deal
situation
then they've got to vote in favor of the
agreement
with as i said the improvements to the
political declaration that's their
responsibility and it will remain the
responsibility of the united kingdom
and of the uk only so that's what i
would say at this point
in this very um constructive
debate in a spirit of solidarity
i was very very touched by the
expressions of trust and confidence
by all the ministers for the work of our
team which of course is their team
and has been for the past two years